We've already seen that
by 1925 Benito Mussolini
was the absolute
dictator of Italy.
He was now Il Duce,
or the leader.
And him and the
fascists would then
proceed to consolidate
more and more power.
And they would use
the threat of force.
They did use the state
security apparatus
to enforce their will.
They took over the press.
They banned all other parties.
But there was also
a popular sentiment
that was supporting them.
People wanted a strong-- or
there were elements in Italy
that were in favor of a strong
leader, a charismatic leader,
like Mussolini.
But then as we
get into the '30s,
in particular the
mid-1930s, Mussolini
starts to become more aggressive
in terms of foreign policy.
And this eventually leads to him
becoming less and less popular.
And also leads him to
getting more and more
aligned with the Germans.
You might remember,
going into World War I,
he actually wanted to
fight in World War I
on the side of the entente,
which Italy eventually does do.
And throughout
this entire period,
he does not want to rock
the boat with Great Britain
and France.
But as his imperial
ambitions grow,
he'll find that he has more
in common with Nazi Germany--
or he's finding more
sympathy with Nazi Germany--
than he is with the
British and French.
And so we go to 1935,
so we're obviously
skipping a huge gap
right over here.
But as we get into
1935, Mussolini
feels that it's time
to really exercise
his imperial ambitions.
Italy already had holdings
in northeast Africa.
It had colonies in Eritrea,
Italian Somaliland.
And he had aspirations
to take over Ethiopia.
Ethiopia, at this
point in time, was
one of the few
African nations that
was not essentially
colonized, or not
being controlled,
by a European power.
It was at the time Ethiopia
was called Abyssinia.
And so in 1935,
the Italians invade
Abyssinia, invade Ethiopia.
And not only is it a
very aggressive invasion,
it's also a very cruel invasion.
They use chemical warfare.
It's very ugly.
Many, many, many civilians die.
And this isn't taken well by
the other powers of Europe,
in particular Great
Britain and France.
But you might remember, based
on what we learned about
in Nazi Germany, that they
were in no mood to start wars.
They were kind of in
an appeasement mode.
And even with Italy they
were willing to make
a secret agreement,
the Hoare-Laval.
And this was a
secret agreement that
actually would have allowed
Italy to maintain control
over significant
chunks of Ethiopia.
But this was eventually
leaked to the public.
And the British and
French public at this time
did not tolerate this.
And so this whole incident,
the Italians invading Ethiopia,
the unpopularity of this amongst
the civilians in Great Britain
and in France, this further
distanced those countries
from Italy.
And the only major
nation that was not
opposed to Italy's invasion
of Ethiopia was Germany.
And so this started to bring
Mussolini-- who in the 1920s
did not think much
of Hitler-- started
to bring him closer and
closer and closer to Hitler.
And their invasion of Ethiopia
would continue into the start
and through World War II.
And it's a famously cruel
attempted colonization,
or invasion.
But these trends continue,
his imperialistic tendencies,
his alignment with more
and more nationalistic
nations in Europe.
In 1936, you have the Spanish
Civil War breaking out.
And Mussolini decides to
support the Nationalists led
by Francisco Franco, who
eventually comes to power.
But Mussolini decides
to support him.
And this isn't a super popular
thing amongst the Italians.
They're like, what are we doing
in these other countries trying
to fight other people's war?
But he decides to
support the Nationalists.
And once again, this brings
him closer to the Germans
and further away from Great
Britain and the French who
are not supportive
of Francisco Franco.
Then you forward
to 1937, and as you
remember Mussolini was
vehemently anti-communist,
vehemently anti-socialist.
So were the Nazis.
So were the Japanese.
And so in 1937, Italy joins
the Anti-Comintern Pact
with Germany and Japan.
And this is essentially
the nascent Axis powers.
And this literally stands for
anti-International Communism.
So they're going to join
together and aggressively fight
communism wherever it might
show, international communism.
And this would eventually be
the basis of the Axis powers
as we go into World War II.
And so then we get into 1939.
And by 1939 Germany is
already aggressively expanding
its territory.
It had already executed
on the Anschluss.
It had merged with
Austria, or you
could say it had
unified with Austria.
It had already taken
over the Sudetenland.
It was in process of taking
over a significant part
of Czechoslovakia.
And Mussolini wanted in
on the action as well.
So in 1939, he decides
to invade Albania.
And this, right
over here-- in case
you don't know where
Albania is-- this
is a map of Europe at the time.
And Albania is right over here.
They're able to overrun
Albania very quickly.
The king deposed the king.
And so Mussolini is
exercising, once again,
his imperial ambitions.
He's getting closer and closer
to the Nazis, who are frankly
the main sympathizers with
what Mussolini is trying to do.
And so by May of that year--
the invasion of Albania
is in April-- but
by May of that year
you have a final formal military
alliance with the Nazis called
the Pact of Steel.
And as you might remember,
this is only a few months--
so this is in May-- this
is only a few months
before the Nazi
invasion of Poland,
which is the catalyst for
the beginning of World War
II in Europe.
Italy didn't immediately
enter World War II
in September of 1939 when
the Nazis invade Poland.
Similar to what Italy
did in World War I,
it was waiting to
see which side seemed
to be in a better position.
By 1940, it felt that a
Nazi victory was imminent.
And it decides to declare
war on Britain and France.
So declares war on
Britain and France.
And this is the formal
entry of the Italians
into World War II as
part of the Axis powers.